اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا كنت مريض سكري
وقررت الصيام فمن الافضل تناول الاطعمه
التي يتم امتصاصها ببطء اثناء السحور هو
التي تستغرق وقتا لهضمها وتطلق الجلوكوز
بشكل تدريجي الحفاظ على مستويات الطاقه
لاطول فتره ممكنه مثل الخضروات وخبز
الحبوب الكامله
احد اهم النصائح ايضا مراقبه مستويات
السكر في الدم وقياسه بشكل اكثر من
المعتاد وفي اوقات منتظمه لتجنب هبوط
السكر في الدم او التعرض لغيبوبه سكر من
فرط ارتفاعه وهي حالات يتطلب فيها الافطار
على الفور بالنسبه لوجبه الافطار
على حبه تمر واحده كانها تساعد على رفع
السكر لمعدلاته الطبيعيه تجنب تناول
الاغذيه بها نسبه عاليه من الدهون وحاول
شوي الطعام او تحميصه وبشكل عام اشرب
الكثير من المياه وانتبه لاحجام الحصص
الغذائيه يعني اذا كان لابد من ان تتناول
السمبوسك لا تاكل اكثر من اثنتين بحد اقصى
وعامل الحلويات بنفس المنطق قطعه صغيره في
النهايه افضل من لا شيء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات